This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. More than five decades ago, an iconic scene in an iconic movie damaged the way millions of people thought about the art of negotiation. In The Godfather, Marlon Brando, playing the role of mafia boss Vito Corleone, is approached by his godson, Johnny Fontaine. The younger man wants a part in a movie, but a big shot Hollywood executive refuses to give it to him. The mafia leader assures his godson that he will get the role.
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。五十多年前，一部经典电影中的一个标志性场景，扭曲了数百万人对谈判艺术的看法。在《教父》中，马龙·白兰度饰演黑手党老大维托·柯里昂，他的教子强尼·方亭来找他。年轻人想在一部电影里演个角色，但好莱坞的一位大人物高管拒绝给他。这位黑手党首领向教子保证，他一定能得到这个角色。
How? Vito Corleone says of the Hollywood exec, I'm going to make him an offer he can't refuse. By the standards of 1972, what follows is violent and gory. Suffice it to say, the mafia don scares the Hollywood executive into giving his godson the role. For decades now, that memorable line, I'll make him an offer he can't refuse, has helped inform how millions of people think they can get their way in negotiations. If you want a raise, or a business deal, or an agreement to end a war, you do it by arm
怎么得到？维托·柯里昂谈到这位好莱坞高管时说：“我要开出一个他无法拒绝的条件。”按 1972 年的标准来看，接下来的一幕充满了暴力和血腥。可以说，这位黑手党教父把好莱坞高管吓得乖乖把角色给了他的教子。几十年来，“我要开出一个他无法拒绝的条件”这句令人难忘的台词，一直在塑造数百万人对如何在谈判中达到目的的看法。如果你想要加薪、谈成一笔生意，或者达成一项结束战争的协议，你的做法就是施压
twisting. If you can make me hurt badly enough, I'll give you what you want. Today on the show, we explore the science of negotiation. What researchers have found about the art of crafting a good deal is more nuanced and more uplifting than the lessons of mafia movies. How to become a better negotiator. This week on Hidden Brain. When we head into a negotiation to buy a new car, to get a refund, to figure out how to
——扭转乾坤。如果你能让我痛不欲生，我就会给你想要的东西。今天节目中，我们将探讨谈判的科学。研究人员对如何巧妙达成好交易的发现，比黑手党电影里的教训要微妙得多，也更具启发性。如何成为一名更好的谈判专家。本周 Hidden Brain。当我们去谈判买新车、要求退款、或者商量如何
divide household chores, our focus is usually on getting the other party to agree to our preferred outcome. We focus on all the ways the other side can be obstinate or intransigent. What we don't focus on are our own biases and blind spots. At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist Max Baserman studies the theory and practice of negotiation. He says understanding those biases and blind spots can help us craft better deals. Max Baserman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. I'm delighted to be with you, Shankar. Max, I want to start with the story of a man named Robert Campo.
分担家务时，我们的重点通常是让对方同意我们期望的结果。我们把注意力放在对方可能如何固执或顽固上。我们没有关注的是我们自己的偏见和盲点。在哈佛商学院，行为科学家马克斯·巴泽曼研究谈判的理论与实践。他说，了解这些偏见和盲点可以帮助我们制定更好的交易。马克斯·巴泽曼，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢。很高兴能与你交流，尚卡尔。马克斯，我想从一个叫罗伯特·坎波的人的故事开始。
In 1987, he was featured in Fortune's 50 Most Interesting Businesspeople. He was a real estate developer from Canada, but I understand he had a burning ambition to be more than a real estate developer from Canada? Yeah, he seemed to be on the search for his new adventure and he explored a variety of turfs eventually landing in the retail space. I understand that some of this was not just about his business interests he also wanted to be a somebody he wanted to be invited to the right parties and so part of his explorations
1987 年，他被《财富》杂志评为“50位最具吸引力的商界人士”之一。他是一名来自加拿大的房地产开发商，但我听说他有着极大的野心，想成为不仅仅是加拿大房地产开发商的人？是的，他似乎一直在寻找新的冒险，并探索了各种领域，最终涉足零售业。据我了解，这不仅仅是为了他的商业利益，他还想成为一个大人物，希望能受邀参加各种正确的派对，因此他的一部分
of acquisitions was connected to him wanting to be a mover and a shaker. A lot of stories that we see in the acquisition world have people who have some ego interest in being on the front page of a newspaper, of making the acquisition occur, and this can often lead people to depart from what we might think of rational action or what's best from a financial perspective. So Robert Campo was a very colorful
收购探索与他想要成为一个呼风唤雨的人物有关。我们在收购界看到的很多故事中，都有人出于某种自负的兴趣，想要登上报纸头版，想要促成收购，而这往往会导致人们偏离我们可能认为是理性的行为，或者从财务角度来看最好的行为。所以罗伯特·坎波是一个非常多姿多彩
character. I want to play you a clip featuring the financial reporter John Rothschild, who wrote a book about him. The reporter is talking with public radio host Terry Gross about what happened when bankers trying to execute a deal for Robert Campo once tried to contact him. They tried to get back to Bob Campo, but he was off having a facelift. He always had other priorities besides his business.
的人物。我想放一段音频，讲的是写过一本关于他的书的财经记者约翰·罗斯柴尔德。这位记者正在与公共广播主持人特里·格罗斯交谈，谈到当试图为罗伯特·坎波完成一笔交易的银行家们曾经试图联系他时发生了什么。他们试图联系鲍勃·坎波，但他当时去拉皮了。除了他的生意之外，他总是还有别的优先事项。
The sideshow in this story is his self-improvement, his flying around getting injections for longevity and face lifts and having people following him squeezing fresh orange juice every 15 minutes because he didn't trust it if it was older than 15 minutes. And so he sort of had a designated orange juice squeezer for a time. So, presumably between shots of freshly squeezed orange juice, Robert Campo decides he wants to acquire a company called Federated. It's the parent company of the celebrated department store Bloomingdale's, as well as other merchandise stores and supermarkets.
这个故事里的花絮是他的自我提升，他四处飞去打长寿针、做拉皮手术，还让人每隔 15 分钟就给他榨一次鲜橙汁，因为如果橙汁超过 15 分钟他就信不过了。所以有一段时间他甚至有一个专职的榨橙汁人员。因此，大概在喝了一杯又一杯鲜榨橙汁的间隙，罗伯特·坎波决定收购一家名为联邦百货（Federated）的公司。它是著名百货公司布鲁明代尔（Bloomingdale's）以及其他商品店和超市的母公司。
There's only one problem. He's bidding against Macy's, which also wants to buy Federated. He basically ends up making a bid, but there ends up being kind of a bidding war. In lots of different acquisition stories, we often read about the fact that company A buys company C at a very high price. And what we often don't think about is the role the company B played in it, and that is that A and B ended up in a bidding war on who's going to get C. So we could think of the Campo story that you're telling where Campo ends up bidding against Macy's for Federated, and I can't
这里只有一个问题。他在和梅西百货（Macy's）竞标，梅西百货也想收购联邦百货。他基本上提出了竞标，但最终演变成了一场竞标战。在许多不同的收购故事中，我们经常读到这样一件事：A公司以极高的价格收购了C公司。而我们经常没有考虑到的是B公司在其中扮演的角色，那就是A公司和B公司最终陷入了关于谁能得到C公司的竞标战。所以我们可以想想你讲的坎波的故事，坎波最终为了联邦百货与梅西百货竞标，我无法
see directly into the brain of Mr. Campo, but it sure looks like he wanted to win at any cost rather than make a financially successful acquisition. So I want to just zero in for a second on what happened in March, 1988. It looked like Macy's was going to win the Bidding War with an outlandish number. The market value of Federated was about $3 billion, but the Bidding War had taken the price past $7 billion.
直接看透坎波先生的大脑，但看起来他确实想要不惜一切代价赢得胜利，而不是进行一次财务上成功的收购。所以我只想把焦点集中在 1988 年 3 月发生的事情上。当时看起来梅西百货要以一个离谱的数字赢得这场竞标战。联邦百货的市场价值大约为 30 亿美元，但竞标战已经把价格推高到了 70 亿美元以上。
I understand Robert Campo approached Macy's with a deal? Yeah, so Campo approaches Macy's and basically says, I'll let you win as long as you in turn agree to sell Bloomingdale's to me So it's basically a side deal between the two bidders something that today's Federal Trade Commission might not look fondly at at all Because there are potentials a potential for antitrust collusion going on in the story. But Macy's basically turns down Campo Macy's had already sort of doubled the value of federated in the bidding war, yet Campo, being annoyed by Macy's rejection, turns around and bids another 500 million dollars above Macy's. It's basically a completely irrational action where Campo is bidding to win at any cost
据我了解，罗伯特·坎波曾带着一笔交易找到梅西百货？是的，所以坎波找到梅西百货，基本上是说：“只要你们反过来同意把布鲁明代尔百货卖给我，我就让你们赢。”所以这基本上是两个竞标者之间的一笔私下交易，今天的联邦贸易委员会可能根本不会对这种事有好感，因为这个故事中存在反垄断串通的潜在可能。但梅西百货基本上拒绝了坎波。梅西百货在竞标战中已经把联邦百货的价值翻了一倍，然而坎波对梅西百货的拒绝感到恼火，转过头来又在梅西百货的出价上多加了 5 亿美元。这基本上是一种完全不理性的行为，坎波竞标是为了不惜一切代价赢得胜利，
rather than making any kind of wise financial assessment of whether this upping the bid makes any sense at all. But he won. It sounds like he won the deal. He won. I once wrote a paper, I won the auction but I don't want the prize. And it's an easy strategy for winning any auction. Keep on bidding until no one else wants to bid anymore. He got federated, but he paid too much. And two years later, his own firm goes bankrupt. And he's ousted from his position as the leader of the firm. So it very much is a story of I won the auction, but I don't want the
而不是对这次加价是否有任何意义做出任何明智的财务评估。但他赢了。听起来他赢得了这笔交易。他赢了。我曾经写过一篇论文，题为《我赢得了拍卖，但我并不想要这个奖品》。这是赢得任何拍卖的一个简单策略。继续出价，直到没有其他人想出价为止。他得到了联邦百货，但他付出的代价太高了。两年后，他自己的公司破产了。他也从公司领导者的位置上被赶了下来。所以这非常像一个“我赢得了拍卖，但我并不想要这个奖品”的故事，因为他因获胜而继承的整体故事并不是一个非常积极的故事，现在回想起来，它被视为不理性谈判的一个例子。
prize because the overall story that he inherits as a result of winning is not a very positive story and It's now looked back on as as sort of an example of irrational negotiation So more recently max something along the same lines happen between Spirit Airlines Frontier Airlines and JetBlue Airlines. Can you tell me that story? Sure. Frontier made an offer to acquire Spirit Airlines. These are two poorly rated airlines.
所以最近，马克斯，精神航空（Spirit Airlines）、边疆航空（Frontier Airlines）和捷蓝航空（JetBlue Airlines）之间也发生了类似的事情。你能跟我讲讲那个故事吗？当然。边疆航空提出了收购精神航空的要约。这两家都是评级较差的航空公司。
Financially, they weren't doing great. JetBlue, an airline that often had very good ratings for customer service and was doing fine financially, decides that it wants to enter the low-cost market in a more serious way to potentially challenge Southwest Airlines, a leader in the US low-cost space. And they make an offer for Spirit that's more attractive than the Frontier offer. We get multiple rounds of bidding over an extended period of time in this story, and eventually JetBlue seems like it won the option. But in the process, the stock value of JetBlue plummeted by more than 50%.
从财务上看，它们表现不太好。捷蓝航空是一家客户服务评价往往很高、财务状况良好的航空公司，它决定以更严肃的方式进入低成本市场，以潜在地挑战美国低成本航空领域的领头羊西南航空。它们对精神航空提出了比边疆航空更有吸引力的收购要约。在这个故事中，我们经历了漫长时间的多轮竞标，最终捷蓝航空似乎赢得了这场竞争。但在这一过程中，捷蓝航空的股价暴跌了 50% 以上。
JetBlue kind of repositioned itselfed by more than 50%. Wow. JetBlue kind of repositioned itself to be more of a low cost airline, lowering quality of service, customer ratings fell. And then eventually the government doesn't allow the merger to go through based on antitrust issues. So the deal falls apart and spirit
捷蓝航空跌幅超过 50%。哇。捷蓝航空调整了自身定位，变成了一家低成本航空公司，服务质量下降，客户评分随之下降。然后最终政府由于反垄断问题不允许这笔合并交易通过。所以这笔交易泡汤了，精神航空
and all this confusion and turmoil did not do well either and in November of 2024 filed for bankruptcy. When companies and individuals go into a negotiation, it's easy to get swept up in the desire to win at all costs. In Robert Campo's case, he saw himself as going up against the titans of industry. But in the end, his biggest enemy wasn't Macy's or the people sitting across from him at the negotiating table. Robert Campo's biggest enemy was Robert Campo himself. When we come back,
在所有这些混乱和动荡中也表现不佳，并于 2024 年 11 月申请破产。当公司和个人进行谈判时，很容易被不惜一切代价赢得胜利的渴望冲昏头脑。就罗伯特·坎波而言，他认为自己是在与行业巨头较量。但到头来，他最大的敌人不是梅西百货，也不是谈判桌对面的人。罗伯特·坎波最大的敌人是罗伯特·坎波自己。当我们回来时，
how we self sabotage our negotiations and how we can do better. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When most of us think of a negotiation, we focus on the people we are negotiating with. We ask ourselves what's going on in their minds and how we can take advantage of their flaws and foibles. Most of us don't ask ourselves about the flaws and foibles in our own minds. We don't ask how we might be making systematic mistakes as we negotiate.
我们将探讨我们是如何在谈判中进行自我破坏的，以及我们如何能做得更好。您正在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。当大多数人想到谈判时，我们的焦点都在与我们谈判的人身上。我们会问自己，他们心里在想什么，我们该如何利用他们的缺点和弱点。我们大多数人不会问自己内心深处有什么缺点和弱点。我们不会问自己在谈判时是如何犯下系统性错误的。
It turns out this is a huge blind spot. At Harvard Business School, negotiation expert Max Bezerman has studied the many ways negotiators foil themselves. Max, you've written about the career of a very promising baseball player named Matthew Harrington. In the year 2000, he was profiled in USA Today and Baseball America. How did those articles describe him?
事实证明，这是一个巨大的盲点。在哈佛商学院，谈判专家马克斯·巴泽曼研究了谈判者自我挫败的种种方式。马克斯，你写过一位非常有前途的棒球运动员马修·哈林顿（Matthew Harrington）的职业生涯。在 2000 年，他曾被《今日美国》和《美国棒球》杂志报道。这些文章是如何描述他的？
As a pleasant, earnest, future pitching superstar bound for the major leagues. So he entered the draft in the year 2000 and he signed up with a major agent named Tommy Tanzer. What were the discussions before the draft happened in terms of how he was going to perform and what kind of income he could expect to receive once the draft was done, Max? Yeah, so basically the agent convinces young Mr. Harrington and his parents that he's worth a very large amount of money. They agreed to put a price tag at a very high number that they're assuming
把他描述为一个讨人喜欢、认真负责、注定要进入美国职业棒球大联盟的未来投球巨星。所以他在 2000 年参加了选秀，并与一位名叫汤米·坦泽（Tommy Tanzer）的大经纪人签约。在选秀开始前，关于他将如何表现以及选秀结束后他能获得什么样的收入，双方进行了怎样的讨论，马克斯？是的，基本上这位经纪人让年轻的哈林顿先生和他的父母相信，他的价值非常高。他们同意把身价定在一个非常高的数字上，他们假设
that the baseball team will eventually cave in and unfortunately they don't. And Tanzer basically encourages Harrington to be patient and wait for them to cave. And under the rules of the Major League Baseball system, a potential employee can only negotiate with one team in any specific year. And basically, Tanzer and Harrington push the team to the limit, and the team eventually says no. And when that occurs, that basically means this superstar who's been offered many millions of dollars in a variety of different
棒球队最终会妥协，但不幸的是，他们没有。坦泽基本上鼓励哈林顿保持耐心，等待他们妥协。根据美国职业棒球大联盟系统的规则，潜在的雇员在任何特定年份只能与一支球队谈判。基本上，坦泽和哈林顿把球队逼到了极限，球队最终说了“不”。当这种情况发生时，这就意味着这位在各种不同形式下被提供数百万美元报价的超级巨星，
forms ends up being unemployed for the following year. So the agent tells Matthew Harrington that any team that signs him would have to offer a $4.95 million first-year signing bonus. Now, this was an extreme offer at the time. The Colorado Rockies, who chose Harrington as the seventh pick in the draft, actually made a number of fairly compelling offers, including $5.3 million over eight years or $3.7 million without a long-term commitment, but the agent and the family and the young man declined.
最终在接下来的一年里失业了。所以经纪人告诉马修·哈林顿，任何签下他的球队都必须提供 495 万美元的第一年签约奖金。现在，这在当时是一个极端的报价。科罗拉多落基山脉队在选秀中选中哈林顿作为第七顺位新秀，实际上提出了许多相当引人注目的报价，包括八年 530 万美元，或者没有长期承诺的 370 万美元，但经纪人、家人和这个年轻人拒绝了。
Yeah, so just to put this in perspective, this is in 2000, so these dollars are very different than dollars today. But still, we're talking about a lot of money being on the table, and we're talking about somebody who doesn't have a college education, doesn't have a terrific alternative career outside of baseball, who's being offered around $5 million in a variety of different forms,
是的，所以为了把这一点放在正确的视角来看，这是在 2000 年，所以这些钱与今天的钱非常不同。但即便如此，我们谈论的是桌上摆着的一大笔钱，我们谈论的是一个没有受过大学教育、除了棒球之外没有太好的替代职业道路的人，他在各种不同的形式下被提供了大约 500 万美元的报价，
depending on the number of years that Matt Harrington would sign for. And Tommy Tanzer, the agent, pushes the Harringtons to be patient and wait for more. Unfortunately, the Colorado Rockies, the baseball team, wants Harrington, but not at the price level that Tanzer and Harrington are demanding, and basically no deal is created.
这取决于马特·哈林顿将签约的年数。而经纪人汤米·坦泽则敦促哈林顿一家保持耐心，等待更多。不幸的是，棒球队科罗拉多落基山脉队想要哈林顿，但价格不是坦泽和哈林顿所要求的水平，基本上没有达成任何交易。
So after holding out this first year, he gets a second shot at the big leagues the following year. Matthew Harrington switched agents and entered the major league baseball draft again. This time the team from San Diego chooses him as the 58th overall selection, but the final offer they make is 1.25 million dollars over four years with a 300,000 dollar signing bonus. Now that's significantly less than what the Colorado team offered him a year earlier and it's also less than what you know Tommy Tanzer had promised that he would get when he became you know this baseball star. So what happens in year two? So we have a very similar kind of phenomena here in terms of Harrington being disappointed
所以在第一年坚持不签后，他在第二年获得了第二次进入大联盟的机会。马修·哈林顿更换了经纪人，再次参加了美国职业棒球大联盟选秀。这一次，来自圣地亚哥的球队在总第 58 顺位选中了他，但他们开出的最终报价是四年 125 万美元，外加 30 万美元的签约奖金。这比科罗拉多球队一年前给他的报价要少得多，而且也比汤米·坦泽所承诺的、当他成为这个棒球明星时他会得到的要少。那么在第二年发生了什么？所以这里有一种非常类似的现象，即哈林顿感到失望，
that his market value has fallen so dramatically. So we can easily imagine that there is an anchor set by the prior year and Harrington's hoping for something in the range of what, at least what he passed on the year before. But during the year he has not shown his potential and his value has fallen. And basically with over a million dollars on the table, and again, this is in a year 2000 dollars or 2001, he basically passes on the opportunity holding off for more and
因为他的市场价值已经暴跌得如此厉害。所以我们可以很容易地想象，前一年设定了一个锚定效应，哈林顿希望得到的报酬至少在他前一年放弃的那个范围内。但在这一年里，他没有展现出自己的潜力，他的价值已经下降了。基本上，在桌上放着一百多万美元的情况下——再次说明，这是 2000 年或 2001 年的美元——他基本上放弃了这个机会，坚持等待更多，
he continues to not be able to pursue playing baseball at the level of the major leagues. And as a result, his value goes down and down and down over time. And Harrington never gets the opportunity to be a major league baseball player. Perhaps because Tanzer and Harrington and then following Harrington and his new agent are basically overconfident that they can obtain an amount that wasn't viable in the first place. And certainly the fact that this happens
他继续无法在大联盟级别的比赛中打球。结果，随着时间的推移，他的价值一降再降。哈林顿再也没有机会成为一名大联盟棒球运动员了。也许是因为坦泽和哈林顿，以及后来的哈林顿和他的新经纪人，过于自信地认为他们能获得一笔一开始就不可行的金额。当然，哈林顿的故事年复一年地发生这种情况，这一事实表明，拥有轮换经纪人的哈林顿团队继续期望获得超过市场所能提供的报酬。["纽约时报"] 所以我听说他在第三年又回到了选秀中。这一次，他被坦帕湾球队选为第 370 顺位新秀，现在给他的报价不到 10 万美元。当然，他之前曾获得过 300 多万美元的报价，然后是 100 多万美元，现在是 10 万美元，每一次他都说，
year after year in the Harrington story is suggestive of the fact that the Harrington team with rotating agents continues to expect more than what the market will provide. ["The New York Times"] So I understand that in year three he comes back to the draft again. This time he's chosen as the 370th pick by the Tampa Bay team and now he's offered less than $100,000. Now of course he'd been previously offered $3 plus million and then $1 plus million and now $100,000 and each time he says,
你知道，怎么能给我开出比我的价值低这么多的报价呢？他成了美国职业棒球大联盟历史上坚持时间最长的“holdout（拒绝签约者）”？是的，最初的报价更接近 500 万美元大关，然后略多于 100 万美元，然后是 10 万美元，我们可以看到发生了什么。随着时间的推移，市场基本上认为他是一个价值较低的潜力股。但他首先在第一年升级了他的承诺，然后锚定在前一年的数字上。他锚定在市场不认为合适、甚至不值得为了让他签约而支付的数字上，结果他最终在一个低级别的零售
you know, how can I be offered so much less than my value? He becomes the longest holdout in the history of Major League Baseball? Yeah, so it was the original offer was more in the five million dollar range and then a little over one million and then a hundred thousand and we can see what's happening. The market is basically seeing him as a less valuable prospect as the time goes by. But first he escalates his commitment in year one, and then he anchors on prior numbers. And he's anchoring on numbers that the market does not see as appropriate or even worth paying in order to get him to sign and as a result he ends up working in a low-level retail
环境中工作，而不是最终成为一名看起来本应走向未来的大联盟投手。所以，是的，到 2009 年，他在当地好市多（Costco）的轮胎部门工作，时薪 11.50 美元。当然，现在看来那个决定真的很愚蠢，但不仅仅是他错过的最初合同。据推测，如果他为这些球队效力并成为一名明星，你知道，还会有未来的合同，这些合同也可能很丰厚。
context as opposed to ending up as a major league picture which seemed to be where his future had been headed. So yeah by the year 2009 you know he's working in the tire department of the local Costco earning $11.50 an hour. And of course, now that decision looks really foolish, but it's not just the initial contracts that he passed up on. Presumably, if he had played for these teams and had become a star, you know, there would have been future contracts that could have also been lucrative.
未来本可以有教练、球探和广播方面的职业生涯。他在前端的过度自信在很多方面可能让他付出了贯穿余生的巨大代价。绝对的，他似乎是一个很好的人，能够很好地应对这些损失。所以你当然可以想象，他
There could have been a future career in coaching and scouting and broadcasting. There's so many ways in which his overconfidence at the front end may have cost him a great deal through the rest of his life. Absolutely, and he seems to be a very nice human being who copes with these losses well. So you can certainly imagine that he
在作为大联盟投手之后，在体育的其他方面还有开始第二职业的潜力。同样的谈判错误也会出现在我们的个人生活中。婚姻中的每个伴侣都可能高估自己带给这段关系的价值。如果我们问浪漫关系中的两个伴侣，你做了百分之多少的家务，根据研究的不同，总和似乎在 120% 到 130% 之间。
had potential for a second career after being a major league pitcher in other aspects of sports. The same kind of negotiating mistakes show up in our personal lives. Each partner in a marriage can overestimate the value they bring to the relationship. If we ask two partners in a romantic relationship what percent of the household work do you do, depending on the study it seems to come in at 120 to 130 percent.
最近，尼克·埃普利（Nick Epley）、尤金·卡鲁索（Eugene Caruso）和我询问了在学习小组中工作的 MBA 学生，你提出了百分之多少的好想法，或者你做了百分之多少的工作？总和加起来更接近 140%。当我们问学术论文的共同作者，你做了百分之多少的工作时？结果是 140%，而实际工作的总和必须是 100%。这里发生的情况是，我们都看到了自己做过的工作。我们不一定能看到
More recently, Nick Epley and Eugene Caruso and I asked MBA students who worked in study groups, what percent of the good ideas or what percent of the work came from you? And the sum total comes up to more like 140 percent. When we ask co-authors of academic papers, what percent of the work did you do? We come in at 140% when the sum total of the actual work has to be 100%. And what's going on is we all see the work we did do. We don't necessarily see the work
其他人做过的工作。所以，如果我们回到我的教育经历，很久以前我是个会计专业，这让人觉得我应该能够自己报税。当我花时间报税时，我的配偶并没有对这项工作给予我充分的肯定。与此同时，说到遛狗，
that other people have done. So, and if we go back to my education, I was an accounting major a long time ago, which this leads to the notion that I should be able to do my own taxes. And when I spend time doing my taxes, my spouse doesn't give me full credit for that work. And meanwhile, when it comes to walking the dog,
我想我平均每天遛狗大约一英里。玛拉（Marla）每天的范围更接近两到三英里，但我认为那是因为她喜欢遛狗。我认为她不应该因为多走的那一英里而获得认可，因为那不是为了狗，那是为了玛拉。所以你可以开始看到，在各种各样的情况下，我们能看到自己的工作、自己的贡献，却看不到别人的工作。
I'd say I average about a mile of walking a dog. Marla's more in the range of two or three miles a day, but I think that's because she likes walking the dog. I don't think she should actually get credit for the extra mile, because it wasn't for the dog, it was for Marla. So you can begin to see the wide range of ways in which we can see our own work, our own contribution, but not see the work of others.
是的，所以通过与尤金·卡鲁索和尼克·埃普利合作，你还研究了一种技术，把焦点从我们自己身上转移到另一个人身上。跟我讲讲这项工作，马克斯。让我们回到这样一个场景：有四个人在一个项目上工作，我们称他们为 A、B、C 和 D。是的。如果我们问他们每个人，你做了百分之多少的工作，
Yeah, so with Eugene Caruso and Nick Epley, you've also researched a technique to take the focus off ourselves and onto the other person. Tell me about this work, Max. So let's go back to the context where there's four people working on a project, and we'll call them A, B, C, and D. Yeah. If we ask each of them, what percent of the work did you do,
我们得到的总和可能是 140%。是的。但如果我们转而要求 A 写下由 A、B、C 和 D 分别完成了百分之多少的工作，现在突然之间，作为 A 的我将会以一种更重要的方式思考 B、C 和 D。我会意识到他们实际上确实做了一些重要的工作。而那个 140% 下降了。因此，每个人声称归功于自己的总和，即 140%，似乎下降了大约一半的过度声称。
we get perhaps 140%. Yes. But if instead we ask A to write down what percent of the work was done by A, B, C, and D, now all of a sudden, I as A will think about B, C, and D in a more significant way. I'll realize that they in fact did do some important work. And that 140% falls. So the 140% as the sum total of what each claimed as credit for themselves seems to come down by about half of the over claiming.
他们仍然在过度声称，但它下降到了 120% 左右。换句话说，你现在关注的是其他人的贡献，而不是你自己的贡献。对。所以我参与的过度声称减少了，但仍然存在一个问题。问题在于，因为我对这个话题思考得更多，我对未来与这些人打交道变得更加抵触，因为他们没有做足够的工作。我对他们想得更多，结果我对他们的负面推断上升了。所以我们减少了过度声称，
They're still over claiming, but it's down to perhaps 120%. In other words, you're focusing now on the contributions of the other people rather than on your own contributions. Right. So I engage in less over claiming, but there's a problem still. And the problem is the fact that I'm thinking more about the topic, I become even more reluctant to deal with these other folks in the future because they didn't do enough work. I'm thinking more about them and my negative inferences about them go up as a result. So we reduce the over claiming,
但我们在这个过程中并没有建立一个更具建设性的团队。因此，普遍存在的一个过度声称的问题是，如果另一方没有做好他们那份公平的工作，我以后就不想和他们合作了。所以，恰当分配功劳的一个方法是遵循哲学家约翰·罗尔斯（John Rawls）的建议。你能解释一下你这是什么意思吗，马克斯？
but we don't create a more constructive group in this process. So one of the problems with over claiming generally is if the other side doesn't do their fair share of the work, I don't wanna work with them in the future. So one way to apportion credit properly is to follow the advice of the philosopher John Rawls. Can you explain what you mean by this, Max?
当然，约翰·罗尔斯基本上认为，如果你想思考一个公正的社会应该是什么样子，你需要戴上一层面纱，即“无知之幕”。你需要忘记你是男性还是女性。你需要忘记你是美国人还是立陶宛人。如果你不知道自己在社会中扮演什么角色，你需要抛开你所有的身份，去想象世界应该如何运转。在多项研究中，我们发现
Sure, so John Rawls basically argues if you want to think about what a just society should look like, you need to put on a veil of ignorance. You need to forget about whether you're male or female. You need to forget about whether you're American or from Lithuania. You need to sort of drop all of your own identity to try to imagine how the world should operate if you didn't know what role you had in society. And across a number of studies, we find that
让人们试着戴上无知之幕，能让他们以一种更公平、更客观的方式思考什么是公正。因此，任何时候你处于纠纷中，如果你能跳出你是房东还是租客的事实，并从第三方视角思考什么是公平的解决方案，你就会更有可能把握住对你所卷入的任何纠纷而言什么是公平的解决方案。
getting people to try to put on a veil of ignorance allows them to think about what would be just in a much fairer and more objective way. So anytime you're in a dispute, if you could get yourself out of the fact that you're the landlord or you're the tenant and think about what a fair resolution would be from the perspective of a third party, you're more likely to have a bearing on what would be a fair settlement
而且，这种使用“无知之幕”的想法在许多不同的研究中都出现过。因此，最近通过与乔什·格林（Josh Green）等人的合作，我们甚至研究了稀缺资源的分配。就像你可以想象在新冠疫情期间谁能获得有限的医疗资源一样。所以想象一下，例如，只剩下一台呼吸机，谁得到它谁就能活下来，谁得不到它就会死。一个 65 岁的人在 25 岁的人到达的两分钟前到达。
to whatever dispute you happen to be involved in. And this idea of using the veil of ignorance comes up across lots and lots of different studies. So more recently with Josh Green and others, we even looked at the allocation of scarce resources. Like you could imagine who gets the limited health resources under COVID. And so imagine, for example, there is only one ventilator left, and whoever gets it lives and whoever doesn't get it dies. And the 65-year-old arrives two minutes before the 25-year-old.
如果我们问这样一个问题：谁应该得到它？我们发现人们往往倾向于利己，倾向于选择那两个与他们自己更相似的人。所以老年人偏向 65 岁的人，年轻人偏向 25 岁的人。但如果我们鼓励人们去思考，如果不考虑他们自己的统计特征，什么才是公平的。现在突然之间，人们意识到，平均而言，25 岁的人比 65 岁的人要多活很多很多年。现在，在我们向其提出这个问题的年长人群中，出现了一种转变，即把这
And if we ask the question, who should get it, we find that people tend to be self-serving in the direction of which of the two people are more like themselves. So old people are biased toward the 65-year-old, young people toward the 25-year-old. But if we encourage people to think about what would be fair if they don't consider their own demographics. And now all of a sudden people realize that the 25-year-old has many many more years to live than the 65-year-old on average. And now there's a shift among the older people we ask this question to, to give this
有限的资源分配给能发挥最大作用的地方，这与我们认为罗尔斯通过戴上“无知之幕”所要表达的意思相一致。我想知道在我们生活的现代世界里，马克斯，我们现在有这么多的协作方式，不仅仅是与面对面、在走廊那头工作的人协作，还有与远程工作的人、在世界其他地方工作的人协作。
limited resource to where it can do the most good, consistent with what we think Rawls would mean by putting on a veil of ignorance. I'm wondering in the modern world in which we live, Max, there are so many ways in which we now collaborate, not just with people face to face, who are working down the corridor from us, but people who are working remotely, people who are working in other parts of the world.
我想象，公平分配功劳、理解别人的贡献、在谈判中理解别人付出了什么的挑战，现在变得比以前困难得多了。绝对是的。你突出了游戏规则发生改变的一个重要方式。今天，我们与与我们不同的人打交道的频率超过了以往任何时候。因此，我们更经常、更频繁地与身处不同地点、来自不同族裔的人打交道。而且我们往往是在没有面对面的情况下做到这一点的。
I would imagine that the challenge of apportioning credit fairly, of understanding what other people might be contributing, of understanding in a negotiation what somebody else is giving, becomes so much harder now than it was before. Absolutely. And you're highlighting one of the important ways in which the game has changed. We deal with more people who differ from us today than we ever did before. And so we're dealing with people in different locations, from different ethnic groups, on a much, much more regular basis. And we're often doing it without seeing them face to
因此，无论是在我们与他们的联系方面，还是在我们对他们的认同方面，人们离得越远，我们就越容易忽视他们对这笔交易所做出的全部价值。你如何解决这个问题？因为当然，我不知道我们是否会回到那种所有谈判总是面对面进行的世。我的意思是，我们现在身处这样一个世界，无论好坏，我们都得接受虚拟沟通和跨越许多时区的交接。是的。
face. So the farther people get, both in terms of our connectivity to them and our identification with them, the easier it is to not place full value on what they're bringing to the deal. And how do you fix that? Because of course I don't know if we're going to go back to a world where all of the negotiations are always going to be face to face. I mean, we are in a world now where, for better or worse, we are stuck with, you know, virtual communications and handoffs that can span many, many time zones. Yeah.
首先，你实际上已经提出了一个答案。我们在多大程度上可以戴上无知之幕，这样我们就不会被我们自己的视角所左右？我们发现，如果我们要求人们采取中立的视角、戴上无知之幕并思考这个问题，他们在这方面做得相当不错。所以并不是我们没有能力去考虑对方，我们只是没有这么做。而且他们离我们越远，我们就越容易忽视他们在谈判中的关键作用。
So to begin with, you kind of already brought up an answer. To what extent can we put on a veil of ignorance so that we're not as biased by our own lens? We have found that people are pretty good at taking a neutral perspective if we ask them to and to put on available ignorance and think about that problem. So it's not that we're incapable of thinking about the other side, we simply don't. And the more they're distant from us, the easier it is to ignore their critical role
因此，只需停下来并采纳对方的视角，不仅能让你成为一个更好的人，而且从战略上讲，也能让你成为一个更有效的人，去理解他们在谈判中是谁。而未能考虑对方的视角，是阻止谈判者变得更有效率的关键障碍之一。我想放一段电视剧《办公室》（The Office）里的片段。在这个片段中，迈克尔·
in a negotiation. So simply stopping and adopting the perspective of the other side, not only makes you a nicer person, but it strategically makes you a more effective person to understand who they are in the negotiation. And the failure to consider the perspective of the other side is one of the key barriers that keeps negotiators from being more effective. I want to play you a clip from the television show The Office. In this clip, Michael
斯科特（Michael Scott，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔饰演）辞去了纸品公司经理的职务，创办了一家竞争对手公司。迈克尔和他的商业伙伴现在正与他前公司的首席财务官就出售他们的初创公司进行谈判。“迈克尔，为了加速这些谈判，我们准备向你提供一份非常慷慨的报价。”“而我们准备拒绝那个报价。”“迈克尔，你甚至还没听到……”“我们绝不会接受他们的第一份报价。你们的第二份报价是什么？”“一万二千美元。你在开玩笑吗？这简直是极大的侮辱！”
Scott, played by Steve Carell, has quit his job as the manager of a paper supply company and started a rival firm. Michael and his business partner are now negotiating with the chief financial officer of his former company about selling their startup. Michael, in order to expedite these negotiations, we are prepared to make you a very generous offer. And we are prepared to reject that offer. Michael, you haven't even heard... We'll never accept their first offer. What is your second offer? Twelve thousand dollars. Are you kidding me? That is insultingly low?
“我甚至不想听你们的第一份报价是什么。”我的意思是，在某些方面，马克斯，这当然是喜剧，但我们所有人现实生活中都会这样做。我们在谈判中根本不注意对对方来说重要的是什么。不听对方说话这件事本身就显得有些过分明显。但在现实生活中，我们经常把谈判仅仅看作是一场讨价还价的会话，如果我们能通过问“我该如何最好地理解他们向我开出报价时的视角”来进行战略思考，我们本可以有效得多。
I don't even want to hear what your first offer was. I mean, in some ways, Max, this is comedy, of course, but all of us do this in real life. We simply don't pay attention to what's important to the other side in a negotiation. There is something kind of over the top obvious about not listening to the other side. But so often in real life, we think of negotiations simply as a haggling session, when we could be so much more effective if we think about it strategically by asking, how can I best understand the perspective
他们在公司里有多大程度上需要我？如果我不接受他们的报价，他们会怎么做？这有助于我权衡我能把事情推到多大程度上对我有利。这也为理解哪里存在有趣的交易机会提供了基础。我的意思是，这很大程度上归结于我们是如何被锚定在我们自己的思维中的，马克斯。我们在这里谈论的很多内容，你知道，都归结为自我中心主义的问题。我们是从我们的视角来看待
in which they're making me an offer? To what extent do they need me in their firm? What are they going to do if I don't accept their offer? This helps me to formulate how far I can push things to my advantage. It also provides a basis for understanding where there's interesting opportunities for trades. I mean so much of this comes down to how we are anchored in our own minds, Max. So much of what we've been talking about here, you know, comes down to the problem of egocentrism. We are seeing
事情的。我们是从狭隘的视角来看待事情的。我们无法跳出自己的思维空间。我们寻找确凿的证据来支持我们之前的想法。我们不会主动从与我们谈判的人那里寻找更多信息。所有这些都是我们被困在自己脑海里的方式。没错。所以你刚才描述的现象有一个绝妙的例子，那就是琳达·巴布科克（Linda Babcock）和乔治·洛温斯坦（George Lowenstein）的研究。他们基本上研究了陷入法律纠纷的人。所以每个人都同意已经发生了一起事故。他们发现，原告的角色——
things from our perspective. We are seeing things from a narrow perspective. We're not able to get out of our own headspace. We seek confirming evidence to back up what we previously thought. We don't go out and seek more information from the people we are negotiating with. All of these are ways in which we're trapped inside our own heads. That's right. So sort of a wonderful example of what you just described is the work of Linda Babcock and George Lowenstein. They basically study people in a legal dispute. So everyone agrees that there's been an accident. And what they find is that the plaintiff's role,
代表受害方的角色——认为这个案子的价值大约是代表被告的方认为其价值的两倍。有些人会说，但这只是一场模拟。这可能只是一场模拟，但一旦我们把人们放在这些角色中，他们就会开始相信他们这一方
the role representing the injured party, think that the case is worth roughly twice what the party representing the defendant thinks it's worth. And some people say, but it's only a simulation. It may only be a simulation, but once we put people in those roles, they begin to believe their side
某种程度上具有某种道德正义，而另一方则在很大程度上缺乏这种正义。["最后的晚餐"] 据我了解，多年来你处理了许多关于谈判建议的请求，并且你经常收到你所谓的“周日晚间房地产电话”。这是一个什么样的电话，马克斯？当然。首先，为什么是周日晚上？答案是美国住宅房地产市场中“开放日（open house）”这一传统。
has some kind of moral justice to it, that the other side lacks at a remarkable level. ["The Last Supper"] I understand that over the years you have fielded many requests for negotiation advice and you regularly receive what you have termed the Sunday night real estate call. What is this call, Max? Sure. So first of all, why Sunday night? And the answer is the American institution of the open house in the residential real
所以周日是人们最常在网上发布公告、说明他们的房子何时开放参观的日子，这样你就可以不用预约就能去看房子、公寓或任何住宅。因此，房地产市场上有大量的看房活动发生在周日。这意味着经纪人在周日傍晚临近时、甚至傍晚早些时候会很忙，因为人们有时会决定出价。所以在这个故事的一个例子中，周日晚上我在家里，当时是 9:30，我的电话响了。
estate market. So Sunday is the most common day for people to post a timer online about when their house will be open so you can go take a look at the house without having an appointment, a house condo, whatever. And as a result, an awful lot of house visitations on the real estate market occur on Sunday. This means that agents are busy on late Sunday afternoon, early evening as people sometimes decide to make an offer. So in an example of the story, at home on Sunday night and it's 9.30 and my phone rings.
我接起电话说“喂”。电话那头是一个自称是我朋友的朋友的人。我喜欢我们共同的朋友，所以尽管接到电话的时间很尴尬，我还是想保持礼貌。在自我介绍为我朋友的朋友之后，他们解释了他们打电话的原因。
And I pick up the phone and say hi. And on the other end of the line is somebody who introduces themselves as a friend of a friend of mine. And I like our mutual friends, so I wanna be polite despite the timing of the phone call. And after introducing themselves as a friend of a friend of mine, they explain why they're calling.
他们今天下午看了一套房子。事实上，他们过去三个月一直在看房子。他们看过了 20 多套房子，但今天他们发现了一套惊艳的房子。然后他们开始向我详细描述这套房子。他们似乎有一种错觉，认为在周日晚上我会在乎它长什么样。嗯，但他们接着说到了打电话的原因。
They looked at a house this afternoon. In fact, they've been looking at houses for the last three months. They've looked at over 20 houses, but today they found an amazing house. And they proceed to describe it to me in intricate detail. They seem to be under the illusion that on Sunday night I care what it looks like. Um, but they proceed to the reason for the call.
这套房子的挂牌价是 599,000 美元。当天早些时候，事实上是在下午 4:30，他们出价 550,000 美元。所以 599 是要价，他们出价 550。那天晚上他们去了我们共同的朋友家吃晚饭。大约 10 分钟前，经纪人回电话说卖家还价 585。
So the house is listed for $599,000. Earlier in the day, at 4.30 in the afternoon, in fact, they made an offer for $550,000. So 599 offer asking and they offered 550. And that evening they went to our mutual friends house for dinner. And about 10 minutes ago, the agent called back and said that the seller had countered at 585.
是的。他们想知道接下来该做什么，因为他们一直在和他们的朋友交谈，朋友说：“我知道该怎么做。给马克斯打电话吧，他教谈判的。”当我接到这个电话时——我向你保证，我已经无数次接到过类似版本的电话了——我问他们的第一件事是，
Yeah. And they wanna know what they should do next because they had been talking with their friend who said, I know what to do. Let's call Max, he teaches negotiation. And when I get this call, and I promise you I've received some version of this call so many times, the first thing I ask them is,
如果他们不买这套房子，他们打算怎么办？是的。他们的反应通常是某种观念：“马克斯，我们打电话不是为了听怎么不买这套房子。我们打电话是为了寻求怎么买这套房子的建议。”所以我一直在试图弄清楚这些人到底在问什么？我想他们问的是：“马克斯，我们怎么才能谈成一笔大交易，顺便说一句，我们不想冒任何可能失去这笔交易的风险？”
what are they going to do if they don't buy this house? Yeah. And they typically respond with some notion of, Max, we didn't call you for how not to buy the house. We called you for advice on how to buy the house. So I've been trying to figure out what are these people actually asking? And I think what they're asking is, Max, how do we get a great deal deal and by the way, we don't want to run any risk whatsoever of losing the deal
是的，对于那个问题，我知道答案是：你做不到。为了获得尽可能最好的交易，你可能需要冒一点会失去这笔交易的风险，而且如果比起“不惜一切代价也必须买下这套房子”，你还有第二套房子，或者你同样喜欢的第二套和第三套房子，只是你需要重新粉刷一下厨房，那么突然之间，你就有底气进行还价了，这种还价会承担一些风险，但能让你谈到一个明显更好的价格。所以如果世界末日会来临，如果你不买这套房子，
Yeah, and then that question I know the answer to is you can't to get the best deal possible You probably need to run some small risk that you'll lose the deal and If Instead of feeling like I have to have this house at any cost, you had a second house or a second and third house that you liked almost as well but you needed to repaint the kitchen, then all of a sudden you're empowered to counter in a way that runs some risk, but allows you to get a significantly better price. So if the world ends, if you don't buy this house,
你应该付 585,000 美元。如果有另一套房子，买了那套房子会让你觉得和买这套房子差不多，而且不用付 570,000 美元，嗯，现在你可以还价 560,000 美元，因为你知道不会有什么悲剧发生。你总是可以转而买另一套房子。所以换句话说，你认为房地产最重要的规则是：爱上三套房子，而不是一套。
you should pay the 5.85. If there's another house where buying the other house would make you indifferent between that and paying 5.70, well now you can counter at 5.60 knowing no tragedy is going to happen. You can always go to the other house instead. So in other words, you say that the most important rule in real estate is to fall in love with three, not with one.
你应该付5.85美元。如果有另一套房子，买这套房子会让你觉得选它还是选付5.70美元都无所谓，那现在你就可以还价5.60美元，因为你知道不会有什么悲剧发生。你总是可以选择去买另一套房子。换句话说，你说房地产最重要的规则是爱上三套房子，而不是一套。
That's right. And for most negotiations, falling in love with three rather than with one is a pretty good piece of advice. When we come back, when to stick to our guns and when to fall. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've all seen the movies of cool negotiators who bluff their way into amazing deals.
没错。对于大多数谈判来说，爱上三个选择而不是仅仅爱上一个，是一个相当不错的建议。稍后回来，我们将探讨何时该坚持己见，何时该妥协。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都看过电影中那些通过虚张声势就谈成惊天大生意的冷静谈判专家。
By exuding overconfidence and charisma, they get their opponents to fold. Real life, of course, is not the movies. The people sitting across from you at work or at the kitchen table are unlikely to be overwhelmed by your charisma and overconfidence. In fact, they've watched the same movies you've watched. They may also falsely believe that you'll fold if they just push you hard enough. Max Bezerman is a social scientist at Harvard Business School. He's the author of several books about negotiation, including Negotiating Rationally, Negotiation
他们散发着极度的自信和个人魅力，让对手乖乖妥协。当然，现实生活可不是电影。坐在你对面工作桌前或厨房桌旁的人，不太可能会被你的个人魅力和过度自信所震撼。事实上，他们看的电影跟你一样多。他们也可能错误地认为，只要给你的压力足够大，你就会妥协。马克斯·巴泽曼是哈佛商学院的一位社会科学家。他是多本关于谈判的书籍的作者，其中包括《理性谈判》、《谈判
Genius, How to Overcome Obstacles and Achieve Brilliant Results at the Bargaining Table and Beyond, and most recently, Negotiation, The Game Has Changed. Max sometimes advises people who are confronting a negotiation to ask themselves an unusual question. How would I feel if the other side instantly accepted my offer? So I'll tell you a story based on my travels. So I've taught in Thailand a fair amount, and Thailand ends up being kind of a center for sapphires and rubies. So I'll ask you to imagine that you take a trip to Thailand. Okay.
天才：如何在谈判桌及其他地方克服障碍并取得辉煌成果》，以及最近的《谈判：游戏规则已经改变》。马克斯有时会建议面临谈判的人问自己一个不寻常的问题：“如果对方立刻接受了我的offer，我会有什么感觉？”所以，我来给你们讲一个根据我的旅行经历改编的故事。我在泰国教过不少书，而泰国最终成了蓝宝石和红宝石的中心。所以我请大家想象一下，你去泰国旅游。好的。
And you're walking down Silam Road, a major market street in town. Yeah. And for some reason you know a little bit about sapphires and rubies, and you're walking down the street and in the window you see a beautiful ruby ring. And your first guesstimate is that it's worth about $5,000. But you don't want to pay anywhere near that because your knowledge is rusty. So you go in, you have a conversation with a store owner, and finally you ask to see that ring,
你正走在席隆路上，这是镇上的一条主要商业街。是的。由于某种原因，你对蓝宝石和红宝石略知一二，当你走在街上时，你在橱窗里看到了一枚美丽的红宝石戒指。你的第一直觉估计它大约值5000美元。但你不想付接近这个数字的钱，因为你的知识有点生疏。于是你走进去，与店主交谈，最后你要求看那枚戒指，
and she pulls it out, and you ask how much would this ring cost, and she says, you know, that ring just showed up yesterday, I haven't even put a price on it, but in Thai culture, the first sale of the day brings you luck, so Shankar, make me a reasonable offer and I'll do my best to accept it. And you wanting to protect yourself and get a good deal,
她把它拿了出来，你问这枚戒指多少钱，她说，你知道吗，这枚戒指昨天才到货，我甚至都还没来得及标价，但在泰国文化中，一天的第一笔生意会带来好运，所以，尚卡尔，给我出一个合理的价钱，我会尽力接受的。而你想保护自己并谈成一笔好交易，
you pull out $1,000 out of your wallet. And you say to her, I can give you $1,000, but not a penny more. And she says, okay, I'll take it. How do you feel? Well, most people feel unhappy because her quick acceptance tells them something like perhaps that isn't a ruby, but rather a red piece of glass. Now perhaps before you offer $1,000, it makes sense to think about how would you feel if she accepted it?
你从钱包里掏出1000美元。你对她说：“我可以给你1000美元，但一分钱也不能多。”她说：“好吧，我接受。”你感觉怎么样？嗯，大多数人会觉得不高兴，因为她太快接受了，这向他们传递了一个信息：那可能不是红宝石，而是一块红色的玻璃。现在，在你出价1000美元之前，考虑一下如果她接受了你会有什么感觉，是不是很有道理？
And this might tell you that I need to have the ring assessed by an independent party Before I part with my thousand dollars now what's what's intriguing about this? Is had she haggled with you and allowed you to pay? is had she haggled with you and allowed you to pay $1,700, you might've been happier, but that wouldn't improve the quality of the glass anymore than with the story where you pay $1,000. Now, this may sound remote being about a ring in Thailand, but many of us end up being busy
这可能会告诉你，在我掏出这1000美元之前，我需要找第三方对这枚戒指进行评估。有趣的是什么呢？如果她跟你讨价还价，让你付了1700美元，你可能会更高兴，但这并不能让玻璃的质量哪怕变好一点点，就像你付了1000美元的故事一样。现在，这听起来可能有点遥远，就像是关于泰国的一枚戒指的故事，但我们中的许多人在新城市找到工作时往往会很忙，
when we take a job in a new city. And we have limited time to look at the real estate market. So we fly in and we make what we think is a slightly low offer and the seller says, okay. Well, who knew more about the market, the buyer or the seller? Yeah, the seller did. Exactly.
我们在房地产市场上的考察时间有限。于是我们飞过去，提出了我们认为略微偏低的报价，而卖家说：“好的。”好吧，谁更懂市场，买家还是卖家？是的，卖家更懂。完全正确。
And again, this is an example, a different kind of example of what we earlier called the winner's curse. They're more likely to take your offer when you least want them to. What I love about the question, will I be happy if my offer is accepted quickly, is that by asking ourselves the question,
这也一样是一个例子，是我们在前面所说的“赢者诅咒”的另一种例子。当最不希望他们接受的时候，他们反而更有可能接受你的报价。我喜欢“如果我的报价被迅速接受，我会不会高兴”这个问题的原因是，通过问自己这个问题，
it's a way of actually pointing out to ourselves, we might not know the terrain on which we're standing, and therefore if this offer was accepted quickly, it would actually tell me that in fact, I do not know the terrain on which I'm standing, I should actually educate myself. And so the question is really a disguised way of telling me, go out and do more research,
我们实际上是在向自己指出：我们可能并不了解我们所处的地形，因此，如果这个报价被迅速接受，它实际上会告诉我，事实上，我并不了解我所处的地形，我应该去自我教育一番。所以这个问题实际上是一种伪装的方式，在告诉我：出去做更多的研究，
go out and learn some more. Absolutely, and when we think about things more deliberately in advance of negotiation, we prepare more thoroughly and we're more effective in negotiation. Max says that he is often surprised by how little research people do before going into a negotiation. One of the aspects of the modern world is that there's so much information online. And this means that we can so often do our homework to have a better idea of what the zone of possible agreement might look like before the negotiation ever begins. So one of my favorite examples is the negotiation context that so many people find terrifying, which is going and buying a new car.
出去多学点东西。绝对的，当我们在谈判前更深思熟虑地思考事情时，我们会准备得更充分，在谈判中也会更有效率。马克斯说，他常常惊讶于人们在进入谈判前做的研究竟然这么少。现代世界的特点之一就是网上有太多的信息。这意味着我们经常可以做功课，在谈判开始之前，对可能达成协议的区间有一个更好的了解。所以我最喜欢的例子之一就是许多人觉得极其可怕的谈判场景，那就是去买一辆新车。
And what I find fascinating about the fact that people are terrified, terrified by this task is that it's so easy to get good information about the dealer cost of a car online. There's probably better than a dozen websites that will allow you to punch in the details of what you wanna buy and find out the dealer cost. And once you do that, it allows you to have a very good idea of what the zone of possible agreement
我发现一件很有趣的事，人们对这项任务感到极度恐惧，而实际上在网上很容易就能查到汽车的经销商成本。可能有十几个甚至更多的网站，允许你输入你想买的汽车的详细信息并查出经销商成本。一旦你这样做了，它就能让你对可能达成协议的区间有一个非常好的了解，
should look like. And going back to your question, if you're going to put the number on the table, you want to put a number that's favorable to you, but yet reasonable enough that you're not so far worse than the other sides that they end up walking without wanting to talk to you anymore. I want to go back to Bangkok, Thailand for a second. As you mentioned, Max, you used to teach the art of negotiation to students there. But I understand that your students would challenge you on your own negotiation skills when it came to hiring taxicabs?
回到你的问题，如果你要把这个数字摆上台面，你想报一个对你有利的数字，但又足够合理，不至于比对方的底线差太多，以至于他们最终因为不想再跟你谈而拂袖而去。我想暂时回到泰国曼谷。正如你所提到的，马克斯，你过去曾在那里教学生谈判的艺术。但我听说，在雇出租车这方面，你的学生曾对你自己的谈判技巧提出过质疑？
So every morning, class started the same way. I was teaching a group of Thai students, and I was teaching negotiation. Of course, they want to know, does this professor actually know anything in the real world? And their favorite way of assessing this is to say, Professor, where did you go last night? And after I would tell them, they to say, professor, where did you go last night? And after I would tell them, they would say, and how much did you pay the taxi driver to bring you home?
所以每天早上，课堂都是以同样的方式开始的。我当时在教一群泰国学生，我教的是谈判。当然，他们想知道，这位教授在现实世界中到底懂不懂什么？而他们评估这一点的最喜欢的方式就是说：“教授，你昨晚去哪儿了？”在我告诉他们之后，他们会说，教授，你昨晚去哪儿了？在我告诉他们之后，他们会说，“你付了多少车费让出租车司机把你送回家的？”
Now, I need to put this into perspective. So this is before the taxi system changed in Bangkok to using meters. And before taxis used meters, you basically haggled with the taxi driver. You'd tell them where you want to go, and they would make me an offer, which would be too high, and you'd haggle. And typically, in about 40 seconds, you'd converge on a price. The first few days, they laughed at me, and they would basically tell me that I paid 40 cents too much or 80 cents too much and that gave them a great chuckle and they were happy.
现在，我需要把这个放到当时的背景下来看。这是曼谷的出租车系统改用计价器之前的事。在出租车使用计价器之前，你基本上是和出租车司机讨价还价的。你告诉他们你想去哪里，他们会给你报一个价，这个价会开得很高，然后你再讨价还价。通常在大约40秒内，你们就能就一个价格达成一致。前几天，他们嘲笑我，基本上告诉我，我多付了40美分或80美分，这让他们觉得很好笑，他们也很开心。
But I would say within two weeks I had some increased credibility based on my sort of mastering the art of negotiating with the taxi driver. But then the problem showed up, and that was my spouse. She flies into town, we go for a long walk the first evening to go to a restaurant across town, come out of the restaurant, and my wife, Marla, she's a bit tired from having flown from the US to Bangkok that day.
但我得说，不到两周时间，由于我某种程度上掌握了与出租车司机讨价还价的艺术，我的信誉有所提高。但随后问题出现了，那就是我的配偶。她飞到了这座城市，第一天傍晚我们去散步，打算去城另一头的一家餐厅，从餐厅出来后，我的妻子玛拉，因为那天从美国飞到曼谷，觉得有点累了。
And I held down a taxi. And in my best tie, I say to the taxi driver, which I think means something like, can you take me to the Shell station by the corner of Jaranpon. And in response to this, he holds up seven fingers for 70 baht, which is basically worth $2.80 at the time of the story. A dramatically high price for the ride I was asking him about. So I respond by holding up three fingers, or $1.20, to which he responds with five fingers or $2. Eventually he comes down to four fingers or $1.60. I'm holding at $1.20, which I've already taken this ride for $1.20, so I know I can get it for $1.20. And he responds by driving away. So I held down another taxi driver who starts at a much more reasonable five fingers or $2.
我拦下了一辆出租车。我用我最好的泰语对司机说，我觉得这大概意思是：你能带我去查兰蓬街角的壳牌加油站吗？作为回应，他举起了七根手指，代表70泰铢，在故事发生的时候，这基本上相当于2.80美元。对于我问的那趟行程来说，这是一个极其高昂的价格。所以我回应说，举起三根手指，也就是1.20美元，他则回应伸出五根手指，也就是2美元。最后他降到四根手指，也就是1.60美元。我坚持1.20美元，因为我已经坐过这趟车1.20美元，所以我知道1.20美元就能拿下。而他的回应是开车走人。于是我又拦了一辆出租车，这个司机从更合理的五根手指或2美元开始。
I respond 120, he comes down to four fingers or 160, and I respond with three fingers and he drives away. At which point Marla, my tired spouse, says, what's going on? And I explained to her that they were both asking for $1.60 when the fare price is $1.20. And she says, so you're telling me I'm standing here because you're too cheap to pay an extra 40 cents? And I said, well, you have to understand, I have to explain to my students tomorrow morning how much I paid.
我回应1.20美元，他降到四根手指或1.60美元，我回应三根手指，然后他开车走了。这时候我疲惫的配偶玛拉说：“怎么回事？”我向她解释说，他们俩都要价1.60美元，而合理车费是1.20美元。她说：“所以你的意思是，我站在这里，是因为你太吝啬了，不肯多付40美分？”我说：“嗯，你得明白，明天早上我得向我的学生们解释我付了多少钱。”
And this did not impress my spouse at all. And so in this story, you have this notion of sort of, sort of is it worth the cost of disputing? So I was literally keeping my tired spouse awake on the streets of Bangkok, Thailand, over 40 cents. And you can simply, you can easily argue that I could have paid the additional 40 cents. So you can see how getting a good deal can take over things. But it is such a powerful story because I think it shows how negotiations, I think,
我的配偶对这个解释一点也不买账。所以在个故事里，你就会看到这种观念，即这种争论的成本是否值得？我居然为了40美分， literalmente（字面意思）让疲惫的配偶在泰国曼谷的街头熬夜。你完全可以争辩说，我本可以多付这40美分。所以你可以看到，为了占到便宜是如何接管一切的。但这是一个非常有说服力的故事，因为它展示了谈判，我认为，
have a way of sucking us in. And then we're almost enmeshed in the narrative of the negotiation that we lose track of the bigger picture. Absolutely. And to this day, I'm still guilty of when I'm looking for a hotel online or an airfare online. I over search to the point where I'm working for a wage that I wouldn't remotely accept if someone offered me work at that wage. So this notion of getting a good deal that I wouldn't remotely accept if someone offered me work at that wage. So this notion of getting a good deal can become obsessive in ways that don't make a whole lot of sense. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore what Max calls integrative bargaining, negotiating in a way that tries
有一种把我们卷入其中的方式。然后我们几乎陷入了谈判的叙事中，以至于我们忘记了更大的全貌。完全正确。直到今天，当我在线寻找酒店或机票时，我依然会犯这种毛病。我过度搜索，甚至到了这种地步：如果有人雇我做工并开出这样的时薪，我是绝对不会接受的，而我却在为这样的时薪付出劳动。所以这种为了占便宜的执念，会以一种完全不合逻辑的方式变得让人痴迷。在我们这期节目的配套故事中——该故事仅供《隐藏的大脑+》订阅者专享——我们探讨了马克斯所说的“综合博弈”，即力求让双方都变得更好的谈判方式。
to leave both parties better off. Max says a crucial idea in getting to win-win outcomes is to negotiate multiple issues at the same time instead of going after them one at a time, as many of us are prone to do. As soon as we have two or more issues in a negotiation, the parties are likely to have different valuations on those issues and if we can find out who cares more about which issue, we can make wise trades that create value and make both of us better off. We also examine the single biggest psychological obstacle to coming up with win-win outcomes.
马克斯说，实现双赢结果的一个关键理念是，同时谈判多个问题，而不是像我们许多人倾向的那样一个接一个地谈。一旦我们在谈判中有两个或更多的问题，双方很可能对这些问题的估值不同，如果我们能找出谁更在意哪个问题，我们就能做出明智的交易，创造价值，让双方都变得更好。我们还探讨了达成双赢结果的最大的心理障碍。
It has to do with a certain mindset that is extremely common. Max says fixing this one error can save companies and litigants lots of money and save relationships much grief and heartache. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now in this podcast feed. It's titled Relationships 2.0 Win-Win. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co.hiddenbrain if you're using an
这与某种极其普遍的心态有关。马克斯说，修复这一个错误可以为公司和诉讼当事人节省大量资金，并免去人际关系中的许多悲伤和心碎。如果你是订阅者，该集节目现在就可以在播客动态中收听。它的标题是《人际关系2.0：双赢》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org，如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。
Apple device. You can get a free seven-day trial in both places. Again, that's support dot hiddenbrain dot org or apple dot co slash hiddenbrain. Max Bezerman is a social scientist at Harvard Business School. He's the author of Negotiation. The Game Has Changed. Max, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. If you have follow-up questions about negotiating and you're comfortable sharing those questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
你在两个地方都可以获得为期七天的免费试用。再次重复，网址是 support 点 hiddenbrain 点 org，或是 apple 点 co 斜杠 hiddenbrain。马克斯·巴泽曼是哈佛商学院的社会科学家。他是《谈判：游戏规则已经改变》一书的作者。马克斯，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。如果你对谈判有后续问题，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录。发电子邮件给我们，邮箱是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line negotiation. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
再重复一遍邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用“谈判”作为主题行。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
We end today with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by Discover. Our story comes from Paul Cotter. More than 40 years ago, when Paul's father was in his early 50s, he began to show signs of early onset Alzheimer's disease. But no one suspected cognitive decline and his father lost job after job. He was no longer able to make decisions and he couldn't handle the slightest amount of pressure. Since there was no medical explanation given for what he was going through, everyone assumed he was having a crisis of confidence and he was told that he needed to pull himself together. My father, as you can
今天我们以来自我们姐妹播客《我默默无闻的英雄》的一个故事结束。本期《我默默无闻的英雄》由 Discover 赞助播出。我们的故事来自保罗·科特。40多年前，当保罗的父亲50岁出头时，他开始表现出早发性阿尔茨海默病的迹象。但当时没有人怀疑是认知能力下降，他的父亲一份工作接一份工作地丢掉。他再也无法做出决定，也无法承受哪怕一点点压力。由于当时对他的遭遇没有任何医学解释，所有人都以为他只是遭遇了信心危机，并被告知他需要振作起来。正如你所能
imagine, felt totally humiliated. After he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's, he was horrified by the news, but I imagine he also felt some sense of relief. Finally, there was an explanation for his decline. And in spite of it all, he still wanted to keep working. And this is where my unsung hero stepped in. It wasn't a single person, but a whole company. A small firm located in our hometown in Buffalo offered my father a job, knowing full well that he was suffering from Alzheimer's disease.
想象的那样，我父亲感到彻底的羞辱。在被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病后，他对这个消息感到震惊，但我猜他心里也感到某种程度的释然。终于，他的身体每况愈下有了解释。尽管如此，他仍然想继续工作。这就是我的默默无闻的英雄登场的地方。那不是某一个人，而是一家公司。位于我们家乡布法罗的一家小公司为我父亲提供了一份工作，尽管他们十分清楚他患有阿尔茨海默病。
They hired my father to handle small tasks like making copies. They gave him a paycheck, which made him feel needed and valued. But more than just a job, they gave him respect, dignity, and a sense of purpose at a time when his life was falling apart. Unfortunately, my father's disease ultimately progressed to the point where he was having problems keeping his balance. One day at work, he fell off a small stepladder. He wasn't hurt, but it was clear to everyone that it was no longer safe for him to continue
他们雇佣我父亲处理复印之类的简单杂务。他们发给他薪水，这让他感到自己被需要、有价值。但不仅仅是一份工作，在他人生分崩离析之际，他们给予了他尊重、尊严和目标感。不幸的是，我父亲的病情最终恶化到连保持平衡都成问题的地步。有一天在上班时，他从一个小人字梯上摔了下来。他没有受伤，但所有人都清楚，他继续留在公司
working. The company told my father and my mother in a very compassionate way that it was with deep regret that they'd have to let him go. On my father's final day on the job, they threw him a party to thank him for his service. What a beautiful, remarkable gesture that was. I wish my brothers, my sister, and I could remember the name of this company. What a beautiful, remarkable gesture that was. I wish my brothers, my sister, and I could remember the name of this company.
工作已经不再安全了。公司非常富有同情心地告诉我和母亲，他们深感遗憾，不得不让他离开。在我父亲上班的最后一天，他们为他举办了一个派对，感谢他多年来的付出。那是一个多么美好、非凡的举动啊。我多么希望我的兄弟姐妹和我能记住这家公司的名字。那是一个多么美好、非凡的举动啊。我多么希望我的兄弟姐妹和我能记住这家公司的名字。
40 years later, we don't know if they're still in business or what happened to them. If I could see them today, I would tell them, thank you from the bottom of my heart. Your kindness during my father's final chapter will never be forgotten. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] Paul Carter of Charlotte, North Carolina.
40年过去了，我们不知道他们是否还在营业，也不知道他们后来怎么样了。如果今天我能见到他们，我会对他们说：发自内心地感谢你们。在我父亲人生的最后篇章中，你们的善良永远不会被忘记。《星条旗永落》来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的保罗·卡特。
This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover. Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit the spirit in their communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself. Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期《我默默无闻的英雄》由 Discover 赞助播出。Discover 相信每个人都值得感受到自己很特别，并赞赏那些在社区中展现这种精神的人。我自己也是一名老会员。访问 discover.com/credit-card 了解更多信息。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。